[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to games past
coverage of e3 2018 I'm Mike here with
Lucy hello we'll be here all week and we
are about to talk about the awesome
Adventures of Captain spirit we're here
with Michelle Coe game director
how you doing Michelle I'm good I'm
great thank you thank you it's awesome
to be here
at history to to present captain spirit
room extremely happy to be able to show
what we have been doing for a long time
no because for the past two years we've
been working on life is strange too yeah
and we will talk about life is strange
too soon in in the coming months but
here we will showing the awesome
adventures of captain spirit which is a
free standalone experience that takes
place in the same setting universe and
timeline is life is strange too and so
basically it will be the first entry
point for the players to what life is
strange to will be because if you play
search in the game look for clues there
will be definitely ins and crews to the
character as the setting and what will
be life is strange - did you know before
you set out to start life is strange to
you that you were going to do this kind
of prologue so - so to speak so no we
didn't know at first the way we create
games with Babbage the other creative
director is that we like to think of a
sort of really of stories or characters
and why we were working on this big
story that will experience in life is
strange - there was some elements from
it that we saw that could really work
also as standalone experience and we
felt that telling the story of Chris and
captain spirits was really a great great
gift for the players a great way to get
immersed and to get to get your first
steps into into what life is strange -
will be I was gonna say and it's free as
well so how I look and even looking at
the trailers you're like it's free it
will always be free know how important
was that for you to get players on board
oh yeah we're extremely happy that we
are able to to give this this gift for
free to the players because it's really
a full contained experience so
there is the beginnings there is an
ending and definitely if you didn't play
life is strange run it if you don't want
to play life is French - it's still okay
you will experience really systole those
characters and hopefully you will find
that it's it's a great experience by
itself but of course it's also there is
a lot of small secrets and nuts to the
first I just went so for the fans of
life is strange they will find some some
elements that we hope they will be happy
with and if the players love captain
Strait we hope also that it's a way for
them to bring them to want to try life
is strange to later right we also think
that you know the narrative narrative
experience narrative general is
something that sometimes the players you
have some players we think this is not
my sort of game so if you give something
like this for free maybe they can try it
and I don't know maybe some new players
will see that it might still be
interesting to play those kind of games
and maybe they would want to see more
with their other life is - right can you
talk about character will be playing as
yeah
so in Captain straits you're playing as
Chris who is a young kid of is almost 10
and he has a really vivid imagination
and basically you're playing on this
Saturday morning it's almost Christmas
and he has a lot of free time because
his dad is just watching a basketball
game and you can do basically whatever
you want on this Saturday morning so it
it's some sort of a small narrative
sandbox where you can compel decide we
want to play with your toys in your room
we want to help your dad with with
cleaning the house or stuff like that
you want to go outside and play with
snowballs or go to your tree house and
for us we hope that it's a way there is
a lot of replay value because you can
definitely miss a lot of things in your
first playthrough there is some sort of
a timeline so if you're not at the right
moment at the right place
you will miss some elements that we
might you might want to experience again
and the idea that chris is using his
imagination I'd love to think he's a
superhero is somehow use imagination to
escape the day-to-day life
some of the darker issues it might be
facing this is really the core theme of
the game so our imagination is a power
by itself to somehow get better with
your life and escape some of the
difficulties of of what's around you yes
we saw in the trailer
obviously Chris's dad is drinking and
he's like I'm not gonna be lectured to
by my son is it just gonna be the
relationship with his dad that's gonna
be explored there was a mention of his
mother so that's also the god of of the
story is that by pushing the player to
become captain spirits and go into this
kid's imagination
you will discover much more of the
reality of Chris of his father of the
family and there is in everywhere like
like you know in the first I should
sweat well you can just explore the
environment and discover documents
laters so you will definitely if you're
looking get to know what happens to his
mother what why is that is drinking and
stuff like that but it's really up for
the player to decide how we want to
explore this and what kind of
information they want to get or if you
just want to stay in his room and play
that also something you can definitely
do that's we hope that the players will
really love to explore all this and find
the different paths and the different
also
imaginary worlds that you can explore
I'm curious what kind of gameplay
possibilities you get to explore I mean
it it's almost like limitless right with
his imagination and so in terms of
gameplay it's it's still a life in
strontium exploration interactions
dialogue and a lot of enjoyment or
storytelling but will since Chris thinks
he's a superhero there is also this new
mechanic where on server interaction you
can just press the trigger and play with
his superpower so somehow quite simple
where you can just you know go to the
fireplace and just imagine that you're
making fire out of your hand like I mean
as a kid would pretend and I think we
all did that at some moment to just
imagine we're making things fly or stuff
like that but there is also moments on
the gameplay where you can go much more
deeper into your imagination and
visit those kind of parallel universe
which are imaginary worlds which some
will be easier to find than others in
the game so obviously max in the
original life strange had the ability to
rewind time what other powers were you
looking at when you were developing
Chris like he was saying that it's it's
the power that people imagined they
would have as a kid yeah it's it's
basically the power of imagination and
we also have to play to play the story
to discover what's more about it so I
cannot of course I cannot say everything
about it it's it's around I would say
it's run 2 hours of gameplay but there
is a lot of replay value so definitely
it's a game that has been designed to be
played a bit several times we also had
in mind the community that a lot of
different players would have different
experiences they could share together
online on the social networks so there
is yeah it's a I would say it's more
than two hours but depending of how you
play it it can be a bit less it can be
way more and there is definitely ending
and some some secrets that you will find
that I cannot tell about today so
obviously life is strange took place in
Arcadia Bay where are we going to be
geographically so captain spirit takes
place in Oregon in a new small town
called Beaver Creek it's not too far
away from Arcadia Bay it's like more but
much more in the in the east of Oregon
near the montains and in the forest and
yeah if you look out enough in the game
you will definitely find some hints and
links with Arcadia Bay look hard enough
you'll see a lighthouse on the distance
oh maybe that I tau is this too far away
what was it that made you why like the
power of imagination why Chris when like
I mean obviously you have your
characters established in a life of
strange and you have characters people
are expecting you to see in life is
strange - what was it that pulled you to
this way you said like nine-year-old boy
almost 10 year old what is it about that
point is life that you thought
supplemented the life is strange sorry
so well it's I think it's a good
question but it's a way we are creating
or games is
first life is strange is about relatable
characters that are really anchored in
real life and where we can use normal
existence and experience to also talk
about some social subjects um some
darker themes that that are interesting
for us so we dealt with a lot of those
themes in the first idea strange and
when we were working on life is French
to a non captain spirit we're also
thinking what kind of new characters and
new situations we want to bring to the
community to also give some light on
those new new themes and new situations
we wanted to talk about and since we've
all been kids at the points having this
story about what it is to be a kid
somehow just by himself quite lonely and
which is dead not really taking care of
him it's something that's interesting to
see that how kids can overcome
loneliness with the imagination but also
because it's also a great way to talk
about those issues of loneliness of even
of heroism with the dad and I want I
won't spoil all the seams we are dealing
with but we always try to find the great
characters and a good story to talk
about those themes and there is links
with what you will have in life is
French so I cannot explain what those
things are but definitely why we did
choose this as a reason for life is
French - one of the things you do and
what I really loved about life is
strange is the way that the emotional
beats were backed up with music whether
it be licensed or whether an original
score what are you doing for captain
spirit so you've had in the trailer
you've there is one song in the trailer
from Sir John Stevens I think the song
is called the Death with Dignity it's in
the trailer and it plays a quite
important part in the game where you
will hear this song in the introduction
in different story moments and of course
the lyrics were important for us in a
way that you will understand when
playing the story there is two other
licensed tracks in captain spirits that
we will have to discover and we're
really happy to have those because one
of what
the same is from a French artist where
we like which is also important for us
as as a French studio to try also to
push sometimes French French artists
that we really like what's been the the
studio split working on captain spirit
and working on life is strange too so
it's really the same team working on
captain spirit and life is French - it's
really a common development
I mean Bach we were working on both at
the same time it's the same same new
engines and technology so it's really a
side story that we were really crafting
at the same moment and so the team is
the same team that worked on life is 21
I don't know with our authors there are
13 on the studio working on other
projects like vampire or twin mirrors
but the team on on the captain spirit
and life is French sweets is really most
of it's the same team as the first I see
strange yeah the studio has so many
projects in the works what is it like
you know like coordinating all that I
think the team are quite separate so
it's more of having multiple different
teams and we also of course using Unreal
Engine 4 for all of the project so we
can still share some knowledge and some
advance on the technology but overall
it's really different directors and
writers for all of the different teams
right what's been the biggest challenge
in creating captain spirit I think I
think the biggest challenge is writing
for a kid trying to make it believable
because we and we we were all kids but
we were kids like 20 or 30 years ago
depends off the age of of the guy in the
team so having a kid nowadays in the
game takes place in 2016 so we need also
to make of course Makarova research the
big challenge was to find the good
actors for motion capture and
and voice actor and we are extremely
happy of the two kids we found that also
said themselves that brought a lot to
the characters I mean when when we go to
voice recording sessions each time I
make sure that the kid playing training
Chris is also raising the read English
lines and I let I let him I just adjust
them if if they feel it is weird for him
yeah because even if we try our best to
document yourself to to make sure that
we write them in a believable way it's
still better to have a kid proof check
what you did right possible Michelle
when can people get their hands on the
awesome Adventures of Captain Spirit
sorry when can people play when when can
people play cattle people can play it on
the 26th of June on Xbox ps4 and PC and
it's completely free so I hope that's a
lot of players will will try it and
hopefully enjoy it
awesome well Michelle thank you so much
for joining us on stage and have a good
rest of your a three week trip thank you
too and everybody if you're watching on
YouTube twitch or a GameSpot we will be
right back with smash bros so stick
around
[Music]
you
[Music]